[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur ce set 8
sport sur tv à 60,18 c'est parti pour le
sommaire de ce un magazine cyclisme la
21e et dernière étape de ce tour de
france 2000 20 est parti depuis
mantes-la-jolie ce dimanche après-midi
un tour un peu particulier vu le
contexte sanitaire du moment coup de
projecteur dans ce magazine
tennis le tournoi future de plaisir
s'est tenue pendant deux semaines au
tennis club de la ville
c'est le néerlandais igor sijsling qui a
remporté la compétition reportage à
suivre
découverte aujourd'hui coup de
projecteur sur le body karaté un sport
dérivé de l'art martial créé au début
des années 2000 et qui se développe dans
les yvelines
plus d'informations dans quelques
instants l'actualité sportive c'est
maintenant sur tv 78
on commence donc par du cyclisme la
dernière étape du tour de france 2020
est parti ce dimanche 20 septembre
depuis mantes la jolie
malgré les conditions sanitaires
difficiles le public viennois a pu voir
les coureurs et la caravane pendant
cette épreuve
un montage de romain respini ambiance
particulière cette année sur le tour de
france 2020 au départ de la 21e et
dernière étape à mantes-la-jolie masque
obligatoire pour les coureurs
journalistes à distance des cyclistes
pour les interviews un village de départ
clairsemée du gel hydroalcoolique
distribués mais les passionnés ont fait
abstraction de cet environnement pour
profiter de l'événement on avait été
frustré de pas avoir de vélo pendant la
période du gros navires us deux et du
confinement donc un grand plaisir tant
plaisir de l événement comme ça se
déroulait cette année un beau symbole
qu'on est précieux aujourd'hui en plus
de ça c'est bien les journées du
patrimoine et le tour de france fait
partie de l'histoire de la france
un contexte particulier qui n'a pas
refroidi l'ambiance sur la caravane
ici la centaine de caravanes y fait ses
dernières étapes dans la bonne humeur
des défis sont également au programme
cette célèbre marque de café réunit deux
clubs cyclistes locaux
l'entente cycliste vernouillet verneuil
et riel et l'entente cycliste du oud
année les équipes à se mettre à chacune
son entraîneur ils vont s'affronter du
coup pendant 40 minutes et doit
parcourir le plus de kilomètres possible
quatre membres de chaque équipe
s'affrontent sur ce relais virtuel est
connecté c'est marrant accueillait bon
j'ai un petit peu de un petit peu un
petit challenge quand même c'est
finalement le club de houdan qui a
remporté la victoire une cinquantaine de
mètres plus loin on retrouve le plus
gros contingent de cette caravane du
tour de france 2000 vingt sept grandes
surfaces possède onze véhicules sur les
100 présents cette année sur l'événement
malgré la crise sanitaire
c'est particulièrement important cette
année dans la mesure où les français
avaient envie de faire la fête de
retrouver des événements sportifs
d'ampleur et le tour de france est
historiquement l'événement sportif
français qui rassemble au bord des
routes chaque année et même en septembre
et même malgré les conditions sanitaires
c'était important pour nous d'être
présent pendant ces trois semaines cette
caravane accompagner ce tour de france à
distance sans contact avec les coureurs
une frustration pour thierry fabre
pompiers à saint léger en yvelines qui a
accompagné ce tour de l'intérieur sur le
véhicule des sapeurs pompiers pour le
coc vides il y avait une bulle course on
n'avait pas le droit d'aller voir les
coureurs man show une fois alors firent
merlette on a pu les suivre dans les
derniers 300 m plus qu'on ne pouvait pas
descendre avec la caravane du tour chez
seul moment où on a pu regarder et
prendre du plaisir
le public a lui pu voir les coureurs et
les stars de ce tour de france pendant
cette journée à mantes la jolie et
notamment le vainqueur de cette édition
le slovène de 21 ans tu as des jo gars
de char une fois les présentations
terminées les cyclistes sont partis du
côté du quartier du val fourré
c'est un événement exceptionnel parce
que c'est l'événement le plus populaire
qu'on puisse imaginer
l'accès est gratuit les solistes sont
des sportifs qui nous semble accessible
c'est des moments inoubliables pour les
habitants ça méritait qu'on se mobilise
pour et c'est inoubliable pour nous
mêmes et les rendez vous l'année
prochaine pour une nouvelle étape dans
les yvelines le département est
partenaire du tour de france au minimum
jusqu'en 2023
avant de recevoir hier la dernière étape
du tour de france 2001 la ville de
mantes la jolie a organisé une journée
de sensibilisation à la sécurité
routière et au développement durable
vendredi 18 septembre pour des élèves de
6 du ce2 au cm2 une démarche
gouvernementale pour la semaine du vélo
en lien avec le tour de france sous
l'appellation les cols du tour on écoute
les réactions il ya ici des jeux qui
sont organisés pour montrer que le vélo
c'est quelque chose de propre c'est
quelque chose qui permette d'économiser
de l'énergie
un travail à la fois sportif mais aussi
citoyen d'engagement et sur l'éducation
à la santé
bien évidemment ça m'apprend respecter
le code de la route avec les choses en
vélo et sam apprend aussi aussi
bien vite les respecter la place chez
matin il n'a pas pris le bus pour parce
que ça prend de l'essence mais on a
marché c'est beaucoup mieux
on continue par le tennis le tournoi
future de plaisir s'est tenue pendant
deux semaines dans la ville hier ce
dimanche ont joué la finale simple
messieurs c'est le néerlandais igor
sijsling qu'un lent qui l'a emporté au
bout du suspense dans un match
d'anthologie face au français yoann tâte
l'eau des images de mélanie poké un
match serré avec du suspense la finale
du tournoi future de plaisir à a tenu
toutes ses promesses
après un premier acte serré c'est le
néerlandais igor sijsling 310e mondiale
qui remporte le set 7 6 face aux
français yoann tacle aux 500 12e mondial
le deuxième set est remporté par le
tricolore 6 3 mais c'est finalement le
joueur d'amsterdam qui remporte le
tournoi 7 6 dans le dernier set en 2h45
de jeu
[Applaudissements]
je suis très heureux ce fut un match
difficile
c'est un joueur très jeune qui joue très
bien on était vraiment proche sur cette
rencontre
chaque point était serré seulement
quelques points ont décidé de ce match
je suis très heureux à propos de sa
probable
c'est une finale qui a été très disputée
bon évidemment vous savez il ya toujours
dans une finale des quelques points
un ou deux voire trois points qui sont
déterminants dans un match de chez type
là ce que les joueurs sont très proches
les uns des autres
donc voilà mais je pense qu'on a vu de
très beaux poids que le tennis de haut
niveau et est au rendez vous encore à
plaisir cette année la troisième plus
grosse compétition de tennis d'île de
france derrière roland garros et bercy a
failli ne pas se disputer à cause du
coville 19
les organisateurs ont décidé de le
maintenir avec des conditions sanitaires
drastiques avec 32 joueurs dans le
plateau final
au niveau national il y avait très peu
de tournois justement professionnels
notamment ses premiers tournois futures
ou les joueurs les jeunes joueurs
professionnels chercher à avoir des
points il y avait pratiquement est ce
que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
de la remise des prix c'est que
président en charge de l'anneau et une
au courage vraiment d'organiser l'auto
mois le tournoi de tennis de plaisir
devrait être de nouveau organiser
l'année prochaine igor sijsling devrait
revenir pour défendre son titre
ont joué ce week-end le troisième tour
de la coupe de france de football
plusieurs club yvelinois étaient en lice
les murs au club de n 3 s'est qualifié
en battant neuilly-sur-marne aux tirs au
but le fc mantois s'impose 1 à 0 sur la
pelouse de saint maur
victoire également pour conflans sur le
terrain de goussainville aux tirs au but
où il s'impose contrairement aux tirs au
but également nov le père sur son
terrain contre drancy 3 un carton pour
trappe contre saint denis sur le score
de 6 à 0
limay sort de cette coupe de france
après sa défaite contre linas 1 à 0 dans
les deux dernières rencontres epona
gagné contre issy l'épopée de
saint-arnoult s'arrête au troisième tour
ils ont perdu 4 1 contre grigny prochain
tour les 3 et 4 octobre
en football on jouait également national
de versailles et réaliser une belle
performance ce week-end contre fleury 91
et je reversais ils se sont imposés 1 à
0 à domicile contre les essonniens
classement cette deuxième victoire de la
saison permet au versailles et de
remonter d'être 9e du championnat après
six journées prochain match pour les
versaillais ce samedi sur le terrain de
saint malo de son côté à poissy n'a pas
joué ce week-end en nationale 2 contre
les voltigeurs chateaubriand à en compte
a été annulée à cause du coc vite 19 on
regarde le communiqué après la
découverte d'un cas positifs les tests
ont révélé que neuf joueurs et membres
du staff était également positif
la rencontre est donc reportée à une
date ultérieure on continue à parler à
football nous avons rencontré au golf de
feucherolles l'ancien joueur
professionnel grégory paisley un
footballeur formé à paris qui a
notamment gagné la coupe de la ligue en
2004 avec sochaux et qui a joué à nice
et à strasbourg il est aujourd'hui
consultant à la télévision
c'est notre interview express
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dès que je suis né voilà sur la plage 14
mois ballon dans les pieds une famille
de footballeurs même si ça n'a pas percé
au haut niveau mais bon voilà le
football c'est une passion et c'était
naturel pour moi de jouer au foot après
voilà j'ai fait ma petite carrière et
c'était cool
mona 2 le premier match avec le psg au
parc
enfin quand on débute de gamins en tant
que titi parisien c'est une fierté et
puis le deuxième c'est la victoire de la
vie dire que ce fut en 2004 j'étais un
bon souvenir au stade de france
je ne sais pas intégrer un club
éventuellement dans les années qui
viennent parce que ça j'attaque ma
neuvième année aux commentaires en tant
que consultant sur bin sport j'aime
j'aime commenter les matchs mais voila
j'aimerais aussi découvrir autre chose
parce que durant la semaine j'ai du
temps de libre joue au golf c'est bien
mais bon faut peut-être faire autre
chose on continue cette émission par du
rugby le club de plaisir qui évolue en
fédérale 2 a perdu ce week end 21 à 16
61 contre chartres pour nous parler de
cette rencontre et du début de saison du
club avec nous en plateau le coach
sébastien roncalli le trois quarts de
l'équipe benoît abarth et bonsoir
messieurs bonsoir
alors on va revenir d'abord sur cette
rencontre de ce week-end
qu'est-ce qui n'a pas fonctionné non les
très bonnes choses
21 16 un jour un duel d'oseo voilà
j'étais un temps fou un moins bon mais
voilà on craque sur la dernière minute
ça pouvait basculer de chaque côté
malheureusement on a perdu sur le fil
maintenant encore une fois voilà il ya
quand même pas mal de choses positives
donc on va rebondir pour le week-end
prochain et aller chercher cette
première victoire bonnot bart est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec votre coach oui
tout à fait oui en effet on perd même le
week end avant on perdait dans la
dernière minute
24 25 24 contre poitiers donc voilà
c'est des petits détails à gommer
l'avancé que ces dernières minutes vont
très très importante durant toute la
saison
alors vous commencez par deux défaites
en deux matches est-ce que ça va être
handicapant pour le reste de la saison
je pense pas parce que on a toujours eu
un début plus ou moins difficiles sur
chaque saison on le sait on a été promu
durant pas mal d'années donc maintenant
il faut faut avancer on peut plus être
un promu maintenant depuis quatre ans on
est en fédérale 2 donc maintenant faux
faux faux accroché il faut persévérer
faut travailler
je pense que le coc vide aussi a fait
que bon la préparation a été un petit
peu difficile il ya eu un cas je crois
ou plusieurs cas chez vous ce qui vous a
empêché peut-être de nom c'est bien vous
préparer
non c'est surtout la préparation parce
qu'on en fait comme les matchs sont
finis au mois de mars
on a repris la préparation au mois de
juin je crois donc on avait commencé des
tests physiques sauf que après juillet
août les vacances les joueurs sont
partis en vacances sont revenus et
c'était très difficile de regrouper tout
le monde pour début de saison donc je
pense que là c'est là où maintenant le
travail va commencer à payer coach vous
êtes d'accord il ya eu peut-être un
problème de préparation peut-être ses
premiers remplacements va je rejoins ben
sur ses commentaires
effectivement
la présence des joueurs n'a pas été
optimum sur la période attendu et
ensuite c'est effectivement un problème
de covile puisqu'on a eu un cas contacts
parmi le groupe
donc on a été obligé de tout stopper
pendant une semaine et c'était la
semaine juste avant le premier match se
joue peut-être sur les premiers joueurs
physiquement et puis même en termes de
mise en place du jeu voilà on a passé
une semaine blanche juste avant le
premier match on a annulé le match
amical donc voilà le premier retour à la
compétition en match officiel c'était
dimanche dernier
donc voilà je pense que oui ça nous a
impacté forcément vous êtes en fédérale
2 depuis plusieurs saisons maintenant
quatre saisons si je me trompe pas sa
quatrième année
vous avez été souvent à la lutte pour le
maintien ce que cette année où vous
allez visé peut être un peu plus haut
alors bien sûr c'est l'objectif
comme d ébène je rencontrais propos
quatre ans on a forcément un peu
d'ambition et on aimerait bien jouer un
peu dans le haut du tableau au moins
dans les six premiers notamment qu'on a
quand même eu un axe de progression
intéressante sur les dernières saisons
on l'entend avec nos joueurs on l'entend
aussi de du public ce qu'ils peuvent
voir là d'ailleurs sur les deux
premières défaites
c'est pour ça que je dis qu'il ya
beaucoup de positif aussi parce que même
si on perd à la dernière minute dans le
contenu je pense qu'on a pas à rougir de
notre prestation et on a été égalité
avec nos adversaires voire meilleur à
certains moments donc
donc voilà il n'y a pas le feu y'a pas
le feu au lac au monde y est voilà on va
se reconcentrer pour essayer de prendre
cette première victoire le week-end
prochain et on va faire un bon résultat
au moins sur ce premier bloc de trois
matchs de novart et qu'est ce qu'il
manque peut-être à plaisir pour
atteindre cet objectif d'aider six
premières places
bah comme du travail du travail faute
façon il n'y a pas de secret à ce niveau
là on sait qu'il ya de grosses écuries
qui sont là nous on est là depuis quatre
ans on se maintient il n'ya que le
travail qui va payer
le collectif après on a eu quelques
départs donc quelques arrivées donc on
reconstruit au fur et à mesure au fur à
mesure on reconstruit mais on a quand
même de bonnes bases solides je pense et
je pense que c'est un moment donné de
façon tôt ou tard ça permet justement le
groupe est il plus fort ou pas que
l'année dernière oui je pense que
d'année en année je pense que le le
groupe mature à chaque fois et comme je
les ai déjà dit oui je trouve qu'on
progresse d'année en année quelle sera
la philosophie de jeu de l'équipe cette
saison s'arrêtera là même notre premier
objectif de toute façon à plaisir sait
déjà que les joueurs prennent du plaisir
justement donc
donc voilà on fait tout pour ça que ce
soit dans les séances autour de la vie
du club et après au delà des résultats
sportifs c'est de faire progresser de
notre collectif donc on travaille
vraiment sur la totalité de nos seniors
voilà ça c'est l'objectif premier du
club la prochaine rencontre ça sera
dimanche prochain contre courbevoie un
adversaire difficile
benoît sajoo en tout cas l'année
dernière on l'est on les a joués je
crois on a joué les deux matches on n'a
pas fait on n'a pas fait le match qu'on
doit prendre donc on a fait un match il
me semble qu'on avait fait une première
mi-temps plutôt catastrophique donc je
crois qu'ils avaient vraiment mis
beaucoup de volume de jeu et il me
semble qu'ils ont eu aussi pas mal
d'arrivées aussi donc non très pour moi
très grosses cylindrées voilà ça va
envoyer du jeu avec les nouvelles règles
on va s'y adapter donc je pense que ça
va être un très très bon match vu qu'il
est le combat ça sera ça sera quoi coach
ça sera en premier lieu le combat
puisque comme dit ben l'année dernière
on s'était oublié sur les premières
quarante minutes donc j'espère que là on
y mettra les bons ingrédients tout de
suite et après voilà il va être un peu
plus maîtrisant sur quelques instants et
bien notamment cette fin de match où
malheureusement on est à deux défaites
alors qu'on pourrait être premier sur
deux minutes de temps de jeu voilà merci
à vous d'être venu sur ce plateau bon
courage pour la suite du championnat
la prochaine rencontre de plaisir est
donc programmé ce dimanche sur le
terrain de courbevoie et on l'a compris
le match ne sera pas forcément facile on
continue à parler à rugby dans le
championnat de fédérale 3 dans la poule
une maison laffitte saint germain poissy
s'est imposé 22 à 15 sur son terrain
contre roubaix l'autre club yvelinois
houilles carrières sur seine s'est
incliné 18 à 6 à l'extérieur sur le
terrain de villeneuvois
mais le club reste deuxième du
classement le mlsgp et lui à cinquième
dans la poule 2 verset est réalisé une
belle performance en dominant massif
central sur le score de 41 à 15 une
deuxième victoire en deux matches qui
permet au club de prendre la tête de
cette fédérale 3 avec 9 points
l'objectif d'un top 3 en fin de saison
semble possible pour les joueurs de la
cité royale
en basket c'était la reprise ce week-end
trap a remporté son premier match de la
saison contre bihorel le score 73 à 63
le match le match du chesnay versailles
contre mon fils a lui été déplacé au 24
octobre
avec cette victoire les trappistes sont
pour l'instant troisièmes du classement
ont joué également dans le championnat
de nationale 2 féminine là aussi c'était
la reprise le chesnay-versailles l'une
des équipes favorites de cette poule a
remporté sa première victoire de la
saison 73 à 50 contre tours ce résultat
leur permet d'occuper la troisième place
du championnat
tv 60,18 vous propose maintenant de
découvrir un sport pas comme les autres
mélange entre le karaté la danse le body
à karaté est une pratique née en france
dans les années à 2000 vous pouvez
découvrir cette activité physique aux
rambouillet à sports karaté en portage
de bixente ah mais rien senti steban et
célia agathe son gauche créé pour un
public voulons pratiquer un sport de
combat sans contact violent
le body karaté est un art martial récent
véronique mesnil de vido multiple
championne de france de karaté et
experte fédéral anime un cours le
vendredi à rambouillet le body karaté
s'est déhanchée nement de karaté fait
sur de la musique ce qui permet de
travailler notamment le cardio toutes
les chaînes musculaires et évidemment
dans une bonne ambiance
il yad'abord l'échauffement la partie
body karaté et vers la fin on fait un
petit peu de renforcement musculaire
on a décidé cette année avec les membres
du bureau de recréer cette dynamique
en ouvrant cette section et comme vous
pouvez le voir il ya beaucoup de monde
ce soir
le cours a réouvert pour la rentrée car
de nombreuses demandes ont été faites
depuis sa fermeture quelques années plus
tôt ils sont plus d'une quinzaine
aujourd'hui
body karaté c'est pas une tare du
caractère des vétérans s'est plus fait
alors n'est pas inconnu bien que 90% des
participants en france soient des femmes
cette activité est accessible pour tous
c'est cette mixité que le karaté sport
de rambouillet veut promouvoir
c'est surtout de remise en forme ça
combat sur soi même surtout donc c'est
pour les hommes pour les femmes pour les
jeunes hommes les jeunes filles enfin
voila c'est accessible à tout le monde
je trouve on est plus détendue dans le
body karaté que j'aime plus faire du
sport de combat que ce genre de la
densité objectifs de l'année pour les
élèves
mémoriser un maximum d'enchaînements en
rythme avec la musique
la séance a lieu tous les vendredis à
20h au stade du vieux moulin de
rambouillet on passe maintenant notre
page agenda
[Musique]
dans cet agenda nous allons parler un
football un match amical est programmé
ce samedi à 26 septembre entre le
variétés club de france et les anciens
internationaux de sos gazelles et les
joueurs du ssc loi dans le stade du club
local
pour nous en parler nous recevons sur ce
plateau la présidente de sos gazelle
véronique chaplin et michael hügi hôte
le président du club
bonsoir bonsoir alors est-ce que tout
est prêt à quelques jours de l'événement
véronique tout et tout est sous contrôle
tout est sous contrôle tout est sous
contrôle on n'attend plus que le public
puisque c'est un match où l'entrée
gratuite et donc on invite tous les
yvelinois et et tous les passionnés de
foot à venir nous rejoindre à 15h samedi
puisqu'il va y avoir une ambiance du
tonnerre je pense pourquoi organiser cet
événement c'est un petit peu particulier
pour s es gazelle c'est tout à fait
particulier et michael est un ami il a
cité à plusieurs tiebreak et c'est lui
qui a pris l'initiative de proposer que
ce soit au profit des semences gazelle
je crois que d'après ce qu'il m'a dit
dans la voiture il a aimé le côté
bénévolat et bon enfant
et du coup c'est assez amusant de voir
qu'il ya des internationaux qui font
partie des variétés qui se complaît du
côté csc loi des gens comme amara simba
amara traoré
lionel charbonnier et puis surtout ce
qui est sympa c'est qu'on va pouvoir
faire des enchères et tous les dons la
buvette etc sera au profit des enfants
voilà alors la variété avec s'était tout
de suite s'est passé comment ça s'est
fait très simplement à travers à travers
jacques vendroux qu'on ne présente plus
et ça c'est fait voilà le variété était
venu historiquement dans le passé au csc
loi et je voulais moi renouer un petit
peu avec cette histoire et permettre à
la celle-saint-cloud de ba de vivre un
événement footballistique avec avec des
personnalités alors le match sera-t-il
de bon niveau
vous qui êtes un expert en foot le
niveau le niveau sera sera agréable on
va dire ça comme ça et puis notre équipe
vétérans parce que le variété rencontre
des vétérans
a hâte de les rencontrer mais toujours
dans un esprit bon enfant à la
compétition ne sera pas intense
justement ça se prépare comme un match
comme celui-là sûr sur le plan sportif
il ya des mises en place tactiques ou
pas du tout pas forcément on anticipe
vraiment le match on appréhende le match
entre tranquillement voilà avec encore
une fois de la bienveillance avec du
plaisir on est vraiment là pour sûr
cette journée pour être dans le plaisir
le partage
tous avaient tous à tourner vers
l'association sos gazelle felisha place
qu'il ya quand même un intérêt sportif
quand même à cette rencontre
on imagine que certains joueurs de s es
gazelle ne voudront pas perdre on est
d'accord
exactement on dit toujours et à chaque
fois les anciens internationaux où les
anciens champions même quand ils font
des matches caritatifs ou de galawa biko
cet esprit de gagne il est il est
toujours là même s'ils disent et c'est
vrai qu'ils viennent pour les enfants
une fois collé sur le terrain cris par
le jeu ils ont quand même envie de
marquer huit heures comme quoi c'est
certain est ce que c'est la bonne humeur
qui prime quand même a complètement
franchement si dans la courtoisie je les
vois mal ce à chaque fois c'est vrai
même si son bagarreur et c'est à peine
terminée c'est la main dans la main le
sourire et puis la troisième mi-temps
alors vous organisez d'habitude et des
tournois amicaux de golf avec des stars
là ça sera un match de football qu'est
ce qu'y qu'est ce qui change
entre ces deux événements est ce que
c'est vraiment deux mondes complètement
a pas ou est ce que finalement les deux
mondes se regroupe en fait le monde du
sport c'est cette hausse des amis alors
la seule chose c'est que le golf tout le
monde peut jouer même un débutant quand
ils ont l'esprit sport pas quand ils ont
été sportif c'est relativement facile
alors que si on prend nos golfeurs nos
athlètes renom rugby match sur un
terrain de foot c'est tout compliquer
c'est vraiment la seule différence au
niveau de l'état d'esprit en a même qui
ont dit nous on vient vers ho c'est pour
tenir la buvette et récolter des dons
pour les enfants sera pas sur le donc
ils vont venir pour pour le fun et
surtout pour soutenir les enfants
justement c'est pour la bonne cause je
vois que vous êtes venu avec
des maillots est-ce qu'on peut les
montrer et oui parce qu'en fait donc le
tiebreak a été repoussée cette année
c'est vrai que nos enfants et ont donc
du coup c'est vrai cette année c'était
une intime planche pour le moment dans
quand on compte bien sûr sur samedi sur
les donc donc un maillot de manchester
martial qui nous a suivi ça qui sera mis
aux enchères juste à la fin du match
mansour bahrami qui est le mec génial du
tennis qui organise le tournoi des
légendes nous a dédié son maillot
puisque le lendemain du match démarre
roland garros et enfin il ya g a porté
le drapeau de la ryder cup qui a été
signée par l'ensemble des deux équipes
le dimanche soir au trianon palace
et puis michael ossi aura des ballons et
maillots des joueurs qu'on vendra et 100
% des dons et des enchères seront remis
le soir même pour les enfants pour
qu'ils puissent faire une rentrée
et puis les plus défavorisés les
soutenir dans l'apprentissage du sport
et la prévention santé
merci à tous les deux d'être passé sur
ce plateau le match est programmé ce
samedi 26 septembre à partir de 15
heures
quelques rendez vous à noter dans vos
agendas avant de refermer ce magazine en
football le fc mantois 78 reçoit ce
samedi 26 septembre à 17 heures le blanc
mesnil dans son stade jean paul david
le club yvelinois est pour l'instant le
9e du championnat on jouera également
sur les terrains de régionale 3 maurepas
jouera son deuxième match de la saison à
domicile contre lemay sport deux équipes
qui comptent une victoire en un match la
rencontre est programmée au stade du
bout des clots de maurepas à l'entrée
est libre
enfin nationale 2 féminine montigny le
bretonneux jouera son premier match de
la saison contre travail ce samedi soir
au complexe sportif pierre de coubertin
une rencontre importante pour les
inhumant ten qui veulent terminer dans
le haut du tableau à cette saison c'est
la fin de cette émission à merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve lundi
prochain pour un nouveau magazine
d'ici là à passer une excellente semaine
sportive
[Musique]